Hello 大家好，欢迎来到意见房间。我是徐菲菲。
我是张萍萍。
本期节目由多品类家用机器人品牌柯沃斯赞助播出。
最近纯过日子人成为了互联网上最流行的人设。
成为纯过日子之前，我们三个人曾经有段时间不断给自己找解释。
找标签、找立场、关心宏大叙事，也沉迷于对自我和关系的反复剖析。
在互联网上，他们会把这样一段经历叫做模证人时期。
在模证人时期，失恋就要分析一恋模式。
迷茫要确认自己是不是奥德赛时期。
看完一个四小时访谈不够，还要接着看解释。
连普通的日常生活都恨不得能总结出一个时代症后。
虽然一方面我们又疯狂的还是在找解释。
但是另外一方面，大家真的也开始累了。
就我们不再想要时时刻刻讨论自己是谁。
也不太想把每一种情绪都变成一种理论。
像我现在就比较喜欢买菜、做饭、收拾屋子、喂猫、见朋友，请朋友来家里吃饭，是个好叫。
就是今天把今天过好就觉得挺满足的了。
这一期我们其实就想聊一聊这种从模证人到过日子人的精神转向。
就是他为什么会在此刻发生？
为什么我们以前都好像有一阵非常的模证？
那现在我们就纷纷想要回到具体的生活。
但我们不再只做于解释世界，我们又该怎么样？
避免彻底的放弃公共生活呢？
是的，就是成过日子人是最近很获得一个话题嘛。
其实他也诞生在一个背景之下，就是现在AI的发展非常高速。
但是AI好像不断的在教我们比如说怎么写代码，怎么写作、画画。
都让我们变得更加聪明或者是强大。
但是其实大家都开始觉得很累了。
也有很多人在说我们真正需要的科技可能不是一直在教我们怎么去升级自己，
或者怎么去把同僚都卷死啊，而是帮助我们去节省经历和时间。
让我们真的可以在现在已经越来越疯狂的这个世界里边不用那么吃力的活着。
嗯，而赞助本期节目的科沃斯品牌恰好就是一个典型的会过日子的家用机器人品牌。
科沃斯他不搞那些虚头疤脑的概念也不会提醒我说，
你要成为更好的自己就老老实实的研发能替我干脏活泪活的家用机器人。
比如说我们都知道的扫地机器人高空擦窗机器人再到庭院除草清洁泳池这个大工程。
哎，虽然我用不上但是科沃斯都创造出来了。
这样的能够帮助日常家务的这样的机器人。
所以我们也看到科沃斯其实一直在用不同形态的机器人去承包具体的家务场景。
让科沃斯成为我们过日子人最靠谱的生活大字。
那开始之前我们玩一个小游戏来测试一下大家的魔症指数和日子人指数。
下面会给大家讲述一些魔症话术请大家分析这段话对应了我们日常生活中的什么行为。
第一题，身体正在提示我现在需要看见自我，我决定建立边界提升主体性。
所以我决定要远离能量不皮黑的场域回到我自己的内在空间。
请答一，是不是要退群呢？
是，答案就是累了要睡觉。
哦，我还是想复杂了。
对，想复杂了。
第二题，我想要重构人生叙事，掌握自我定义的自主权。
所以我决定要重新寻找一个能够产生深度共评的共同体。
请答一，分手。
呃，类似，差不多，就是分手或者是要辞职，要换工作。
哦，现在这个工作已经不是能和我深度共评的共同体了，所以要换一个新的。
换一个，是的，是的。
第三个，感谢你的提问，但目前我还需要学习才能掌握和问题共处的能力。
请答一，你的问题我回答不上来。
对，我不知道，叮叮叮。
哎，那你的这个魔掌指数很高啊，咱们这个题就相当于五连外掌里边考李大嘴的那个题。
答对十八道题那是不折不扣的变态傻人狂啊。
魔掌人的叙事效率好低啊，分手其实两个字就能说清楚，辞职两个字也能说清楚。
但是魔掌时期要说一整段那么长的话，而且都不知道要干嘛。
那我们现在也可以通过这个题目来了解一下大家心里的魔掌人跟日子人是怎么定义的。
我觉得魔掌人就是凡事都不能只说凡事，就是沉迷解释，沉迷定义。
我刚觉得小石三个题说的都非常好啊，就是辞职我们不能说辞职，分手我们不能说分手。
吃饭我们不能说吃饭，我们要说抗炎控堂DJI，长道军群平衡。
看电影我们不能只说好看，我们要知道导演的普戏作者性，我们要凝视这个结构。
要知道这个电影的三层结构什么的，如果懒得出门，那就是前额夜受损了，正在进行能量管理。
如果失恋了，绝对不可能是他就是不喜欢我，这个人就是不行。
但是要追溯一连类型，比如他是回避型而我是恐惧焦虑型。
要追溯原生家庭，要测试他有没有NPD的倾向，要课体分离，我们两个是不是创伤绑定了？
就是一切都有深层原因。
对，这段是灌口，听到我都有点晕词了，怎么这么多词啊？
立结了。
好，我们来说点人话，但是日子人呢我觉得就是凡事就让他指示凡事，
就吃饭，就是因为我饿了，睡觉就是因为我困了。
我愿意看短剧，就认为还不错，挺好看的。
我买菜做饭，就是因为我想做饭，分手可能就是不合适。
今天心情不好，我觉得也不用回溯到童年创伤的。
日子人就是他拒绝每一分钟都必须被解释，被优化，被赋予意义。
因为人的生活其实就是靠这些可能不重要的事，
或者是没有每一件都能找到意义的事情组成的。
你可以有非常完整的人生理论，但是冰箱里没有菜，你还是得下楼买菜。
你可以完成自己的主体性重建，但是袜子和内裤还是得分开写。
我刚才听着张评就是解释这些定义，我脑子里出现那种接彩画面，
就是比如说在菜场门口就有一个做短视频的人说，
哎，请问你今天为什么买菜？
然后模证人就会回答，
今天我选择买菜而不是点外卖，
是因为我决定重启与周围世界建立连结的时刻。
然后日子人说，倒点了就买菜，脑子那么多，为什么？
别站在这儿耽误我瞧半家菜了。
所以我从这个分析里我也大概理解了这两个的区别，
模证人是沉迷解释的，总想给这个世界找到一个终极解释。
就算是睡觉我也要找到我为什么要睡觉的原因，
他关心宏大学时，对自己的人生也需要时刻进行精神分析来解释自我。
那过日子人呢就是厌倦解释，
我为什么哭？
因为想哭，为什么吃？因为想吃。
然后我昨天看见人科有一段采访，
他说，意义就是假权，想多了威胁健康。
然后刚才张平说到日子人就是凡事，只是凡事本身嘛。
我就想到有一段流传很广的，快问快答是问炎妮的，
就说朋友们都形容炎妮是大智若鱼，
你觉得你是什么？
炎妮说，我也没看到我的大智，也没看到我的鱼，
我看到了我的弱，弱就是好笑的意思，
我感觉我的人生就是个好笑。
下面来一个互动环节，我们三个人互平，
对方到底是魔证人还是日子人？
第一个，张平是，日子人。
我觉得他之前也是魔证人，可能现在也是日子人。
好，有理。
现在，许妃妃，日子人，自平也是日子人。
林邦，魔证人。
还不知道现在自我改造成功没有，
反正还是可能魔证人演续的状态。
那我们先请魔证人方丹说说，
因为之前其实我们讨论这个选题的时候，
我看好多互联网上批判魔证人的那些句子，
我都完全直接就对号入座了，
什么失恋要谈，一脸类型那不就是我们，
而且我谈的还不只是一脸类型，
我还得谈NBTI，政治倾向测试，
什么纽约时报的三十六个问题等等吧。
因为我自己的职业属性和学科背景，
其实就是非常强分析的属性。
因为我之前学的是心理学，
然后来去做记者的工作，
他就致力于分析和产生一切。
比如说我自己谈恋爱的时候，
有一些前人这也被我折磨得很痛苦，
因为我在一起之前，
Date阶段我就先发五套测试题，
就跟人家面试要五轮一样，
然后有一个前人跟我在一起之前，
我考试就考了他七天，
当时我是网练分线到广州的出租，
找他见面嘛，
结果他完全没想到见面的时候，
他挑战刚刚开始了，
他以为见面已经是一个next level，
然后包括那我所有的东西做完之后，
其实我不是说要得到什么每个维度的分数，
而是这一测试我想要从他做完之后，
找出一个人物稿的主题，
然后最终我希望自己能够给他出一个。
稿子，但是直线的稿子里边不是一定要写，
我想通过这些问题，
比较高效率的知道他是个什么样的人，
他身上的核心的命题是什么，
他如果写一篇稿子的话，
他的稿子的文学性是什么，
公共性什么，
他的人生意象是什么，
所以还不是咱们谈恋爱场见的那种，
今天聊聊创生，
明天聊聊前任，
我是先发觉他的文学性的母帖，
然后从那条线开始，
包括什么，
普通生活恨不得总结出时代症后，
这个必须总结，
因为我每周四都得报选题，
已经持续三四年的时间了，
而且我所工作的这个平台，
它有个专栏，
它就叫时代精神症后，
之前比如说我们有一个选题，
是说,
现在很多年轻人不喜欢跟同事聊天了，
然后最终这个稿子发出来，
我起的标题叫做，
职场断侵年轻人的低电生存，
就是我们的工作，
就是不断的抽象和发明标签去概括事实，
但是我也特别能理解，
因为我其实也有过 MBTI 刚出来的时候，
所有人都开始用这个分析，
每每聚餐认识新的人，
大家都是以这个话题为切入点的，
我就赶紧召集茅荒去测了，
我那时候才意识到，
如果你不做这个测试，
我就没有社交货币了，
因为我没有标签，
我就不知道我怎么跟人家说，
我是一个什么样的人，
第一次测的时候，
我特别冲击，
待会儿毕业测了八年前，
我说世界上，
居然有人这么懂我，
比我自己还懂我，
我是对我自己可能有个比较模糊的认识，
但是 MBTI 居然能够。
高度凝联的语言告诉我说，
我的快乐是来源于我对痛苦的见望，
我说，我靠，
我自己都没有发现我隐藏脆弱，
居然被融格看见了，
我妈都没有这么深入了解我，
但是融格做到了，
她甚至分析了我在什么样的环境里更舒服，
我适合什么样的职业，
还把我过去就是
20多年日子人，
从来没有系统梳理过的我的情感，
用一种高度凝联的语言讲出来，
我非常震撼，
为此我沉迷 MBTI 很久，
沉迷梳理自己，
这几年就是梳理越来越多，
我发现我已经跟不上了，
这生活中的系统梳理已经多到。
没有必要的程度了，
我已经不想再梳理了，
我觉得我的生活已经要。
还要兴奋到什么地步。
对，我第一次听说，
某证人和日子人是在那个。
电影《一战在战》，
听那个影评的时候波米说的，
这个电影其实就是讨论身份政治的破产嘛，
而身份政治的破产，
本质上都和极左极右所标榜的，
都是明确相关的，
《一战在战》里面，
无非有两个人物，
一个是新恩潘事业的军官，
然后另外一个是那个泰勒事业的母亲，
这两个最激进的人，
都是被判了各自的阵营的，
波米就说他们俩形成了一种。
二级管共证，
PTA 呢没有说极右或者极左错，
他只是说你们这些干最激进的事的人，
只是迷恋暴力，迷恋权力，
所以PTA最终反的是那个极化，
但是呢里面另一个角色就是小李子，
他是演的Bob，就是日子人，
他其实是不沉迷于暴力或者权力，
或者是这种宏大的革命的斗争的敘事的，
就是那热血下头之后呢，
他就安生过日子了，
像孩子Villa，
他的亲生母亲，
是为了这个宏大的左翼的革命理念，
抛弃了女儿的，
那亲生父亲呢，
十几年来没有承担过父子的人，
在见到女儿的第一课，
还是决定把它献祭掉，
所以真正照顾孩子的，
不是这两个，
不是亲生的妈妈，
或者是亲生的爸爸，
而是一个日子人Bob，
孩子生下来的时候，
是他天天照顾孩子，
复余婴儿，
所以他是在通过这种复职的对照，
合理化Bob作为日子人，
极其简单的概念，
就是这个人的理想，
没有那么宏大，
没有那么先进，
没有那么进步，
常常是被陌视的，
甚至是被讽刺的，
那现在我们就想先聊一聊，
我们和社会的磨症时刻，
就我们曾经为什么那么执着于，
成长成功表达，
立场自我实现这种话书呢？
对，我觉得刚刚张萍说的有一句话，
很重要就是，
日子人不是没有理想嘛，
而是不会为了
哄大的理念，
概念，产事，
去牺牲，
或者去伤害具体的人，
所以我感觉有一些，
比较典型的磨症时刻，
其实我还是，
为什么会把它定义为磨症时刻，
它肯定是给具体人带点伤害，
而不是只是说，
我看了好的NBTI，
然后觉得过了一种很抽象的生活，
所以其实很重要的一个点就是，
我发现我经常会把，
情感问题政治化，
尤其是亲密关系当中的，
各种私人问题，
放到公共议题的框架下面去审视，
它有时候就会上水矛盾，
前面不是说每次，
Date的时候在一起，
确定关系前我都会先考试吗？
不仅如此，
我还会像面试一样，
靠问对方的信息识谱，
刚认识的时候我就会问，
你最长干的三个公众号是什么，
多干电影TOP10是什么，
最近看的三文书是什么，
肯定还是误伤了很多人，
但很长一段时间，
其实我都会困扰于一个问题，
就是我确定关系之后，
我会跟伴侣有那种，
一体观念上的冲突，
比如说有一件事，
就是我和一位前任，
之前在街上看见一个，
局持有点怪异，
大吼大叫的一位中年女性，
然后前任大使就说了一句话，
他说,
我觉得他发泄情绪的方式有点自我，
我听到这句话之后，
我就立马觉得特别被冒犯，
很不舒服，
我说你怎么能用一个道德判断，
自我这个词去形容他呢？
你怎么知道他在发泄情绪呢？
你这一句话怎么会有这么多问题呢？
万一对方只是有精神障碍呢？
你用这种道德判断去，
对一个可能有精神障碍的人，
下注判断的话，
会不会是一种污名坏呢？
所以我马上就进入到一题的那种反应里边，
好像就是马上硬战了，
想到的一题就是精神障碍者的污名坏嘛，
我就一直开始开炮，
说有的人可能只是需要帮助，
却被你贴上这样的标签，
不不不不，
说了一大堆，
那他听了之后，
其实就感觉挺莫名其妙的，
我后来，
我也觉得我挺莫名其妙的，
然后后来其实另外一个朋友，
我跟他分享这件事，
他就说，
好像我跟朋友之前也是这样，
我总是会，
不断地划向一种关键的战斗，
有可能最开始人家也没想这么多，
但是我会立即，
就是抓住那个议题，
或者人家也没想跟你聊这个，
但那个朋友说，
这可能也是一种硬接反应，
因为我平常可能在我的语境里边，
经常需要进行这样关键的捍卫，
这样的时刻非常多，
所以我总会觉得，
到处都是敌人，
连自己的伴侣也不放过，
他这么一分析，
我是这种关键战斗的硬接反应，
我一下子就觉得自己被理解了，
就还是这种抽象的观念，
他最后了愈了我，
然后包括我一直以来，
到现在吧，
我觉得情感连接，
最深的一个朋友，
也是观念性的连接，
他跟我写那种小作文，
就会引用阿伦特的话，
他说真正的理解是一种政治行为，
我看到这几话，
在明星片上的时候，
我特别感动，
比如说有的时候，
我跟他明明在聊一个政治议题，
没有在聊自己生活中的事，
聊着聊着，
两个人突然觉得聊出一个选题，
情难资金，
就直接开始拥吻了，
下面的内容，
我就不用说了，
停停停停停，
人家的信仗里，
是肉体带来的，
我是选题带来的，
就纯魔真人，
真的把伯克当成你的卧室？
没那么大，
他就把伯克当床，
陈当床，
其实我刚才听方丹说那些问题，
我觉得这些问题，
都不是他去应证，
而是他通过答案，
在筛选，
或者说让人变成，
魔证人，
就比如说，
方丹要问我，
你最近看的三本书，
我实际上看的三本书，
是三本网文，
但是如果方丹问我，
我就会说，
亲爱烂的三本，
跟爸爸，
你的夏天还好吗？
什么什么，
就是我会说这个，
但实际上，
我天天晚上看的，
就是那个，
和笑草的101次初恋，
三个问题，
我第一反应就是，
他通过这个三个问题，
是一种服从性测试，
假如我喜欢你，
我就算是日子人，
我也得装成魔证人，
哎呀太对了，
我立刻开始看三本，
那个正常能拿得出手的书，
本来看的是那个阿衰123，
也不敢说了，
其实我想要的正确答案，
就是笑草的101次初恋，
每压车，
每压重题，
其实想要日子人，
想要是跟我不一样的人，
但是如果你问我，
如果我喜欢你，
我就会不敢回答，
对，其实有可能，
根本不会说真实的情况，
对对,
实际上真实，
这个人到底是日子人，
还是魔证人，
还是得靠过日子来验证，
对，是吧，
我以前曾经日子人，
已经到了一种很深的地步，
我基本上不会花时间去思考那些，
深的东西，
但也是开始做记者之后，
就一点点，
关于社会议题的理解，
在感染我嘛，
然后再到去年，
开始做自媒体，
做脱口秀，
我发现，
我确实需要一些魔证人时刻，
就是如果我只写故事，
发现我没有办法收尾，
我没有底，
像我这几天，
就在记录我自己最近的，
一个喜剧，
事业进程嘛，
盘点完，
我就问我说，
我这个盘点，
难道只是为了盘点嘛，
我一定还有什么，
想表达的东西，
然后于是我就在最后，
加了一个，
我说,
30岁真好，
想到什么，
就去做什么，
然后,
我又因为要发自媒体嘛，
我就说，
这个东西还得要有，
流量,
然后于是我就加上了话题，
30岁是新的18岁，
做成长，
主题秀，
女性成长的故事，
我这几年有一个概念，
在被社交媒体无限放大，
然后影响了我，
就是自我实现这个概念，
就以前自我实现，
就是一种内在驱动，
但现在就是一种外在的表演，
就是你事情做了不说，
等于没做，
你成长了，
你不说呢，
你就是没成长，
所以你要证明，
记得存在价值，
你就需要不停的，
通过,
模证时刻，
来证明自己，
我成长了，
我成功了，
我再表达了，
我最近在读流动的现代性，
其实是为了这个选题，
专门读的，
本来是读的网文，
你别人这个作者，
抱慢就说，
以前大家的生活圈子，
职场圈子是不流动的，
是固态的，
所以你一些东西，
你可以不表达，
但是现在，
社交网络信息，
它改变了社会的运行方式，
而且这个运行方式，
是时刻在变化的，
你就得不停的变，
所以自我实现，
这个定义也在不停的变，
所以如果你没有去，
立刻的了解，
现在最新的，
摩证人，
确立出来的，
自我实现的词是什么，
你就相当于没有自我实现，
所以这个时候，
自我实现，
就不是一个终点了，
不是说，
我拿了什么透过秀第一，
我就是实现了，
而是一个过程，
你就得不停的证明自己，
然后来确保我在这个社会里身，
还在跟着这个社会，
一起前进的，
摩证人归根，
到底就是太像进步了，
因为今年上半年，
我就是一直在读红楼梦，
就如今似可的读，
就从来没有那么好的，
阅读体验，
但是,
我就会发现，
前进在自己的世界里，
然后经常刷微博的时候，
就觉得，
微博,
我看不懂，
觉得自己的时间和别人的时间，
有点脱钩了，
当时,
我们做了一个播客，
他是很缓慢的，
很缓慢流动的，
然后可能每一些细节里面，
都有很，
很小的一些动物的时刻，
至少在聊的时候，
我就会觉得，
好有趣，
但是,
嗯,
后面包装的时候，
我就会，
就害怕，
传播不好嘛，
我就想了一个，
就说奥德赛时期，
什么的，
就想着蹭这个热点，
然后曉旭跟我说，
这个奥德赛时期，
已经过十一个月了，
那一期，
很多听众也说，
不知所云什么的，
但我觉得有的时候，
他就是，
现在的模证时刻可能，
他就需要你，
更高效，
更结构性的，
更,
至少是一种逻辑性的，
去整理一个问题吧，
实际上，
这跟一些学科，
就是相辈的，
我不太知道，
我的模证时刻是什么，
我就问我的GPT，
我说,
然后他说，
我觉得你有文化分析，
不行模证，
就看小说电影，
说回现象的时候，
你很少停在，
我喜欢，
或者我不喜欢，
你很容易追问，
这个叙师，
为什么这样成立，
他和时代有什么关系，
人物为什么反复什么这个词，
这个情绪为什么，
猜好在现代流行，
而不是在过去流行，
比如,
牛来,
聊一个动画，
你能一论，
聊到动画工业，
接计话语，
和舆论中的公共参与，
然后,
这BT说,
这BT原话就说，
你的脑子好像一个编辑部，
任何东西经过以后，
都想给他起标题，
太准了，
你的级别贴，
其实我刚刚听江评的这一段，
我其实觉得特别有吸引力，
就是我看到的，
就是很，
正常的人问社科的乐趣，
就是你在讲述你自己喜欢的事情，
你在里边可能感受到，
这种心流的体验，
你可以忘记时间，
就好像，
小的时候看那个，
夏洛克佛尔摩斯，
他在做推理的时候，
其实也是，
他的脑海当中，
可能所有的线索，
就像一块块地图一样展开，
他在房间里，
看起来是在打坐，
但是他头脑里面，
有无穷进的，
这种,
推理的乐趣，
这个就是一个人，
沉浸在自己的世界里的乐趣，
那为什么，
我们现在有一些东西，
把他,
好像用魔阵人，
这样的词去概括，
其实,
我也想到，
刚刚菲菲说的分析嘛，
就是说，
魔阵人是不是太想进步了呢？
就我感觉，
很多大家说的魔阵人，
我从当中是感受到，
专门是感受到，
一种控制于，
或者控制的指念，
你不仅是，
想要做分析的控制于，
你想要知道，
关于自己的真相，
我的创伤的来源，
到底是什么，
想要在做表达上，
做到,
什么样的实现，
还是说，
你去产视别人，
像我想要在关系一出，
我就搞清楚，
这个人人性的真相，
好让之后，
几十年，
或者是，
这段关系完全都不翻车，
但其实，
这样的产视，
他根本没有办法抵达，
我们想要控制的，
这种欲望的重点，
嗯,
而且,
像我们这个行业，
很多人其实都很喜欢分析嘛，
或者是像，
人文社科的学生，
有些学科，
他本身像文化研究，
他就是去做分析，
和文本的比较，
这就是我们在教育当中，
接受的训练，
呃,
包括也，
可能是我们工作，
给我们提的需求，
张平写的那个，
牛来,
东亚,
我觉得那篇文章，
特别有意思，
然后我看着，
我也觉得分析的特别好，
短身,
这就是我们喜欢的事情嘛，
有什么程度才叫，
模证,
从这种我们，
热爱的，
起点的分析，
到,
事实分析，
过渡产式，
乃至困扰自己，
伤害他人，
其实他还是有界限的，
所以,
呃,
在社会层面，
究竟这个概念是怎么提出来的，
什么,
叫做解释过剩呢？
你就会发现，
这个社会上的一些东西，
不知不觉，
会影响你做出一些，
模证的事儿，
就比如现在，
我觉得，
社会模证化的时刻，
表现之一，
就是,
我们已经进入了，
我们看到一个博主啊，
他叫啊，
他就说，
是断舍离，
是极艰主义，
是优化结构，
是降本增效，
是娱乐智商，
是二十七时，
其实恨恨秦天，
是爱你老几时，
是逃避时，
是重生时，
是找为主体性时，
是去年，
是前个月，
是大女主时，
大结果，
对,
张平作为日子人，
他有一个特点，
就是他不怎么，
晚上冲浪，
但我是，
这种,
晚上冲浪的日子人，
所以我就会对这些，
说袁世凯，
他是靠土淳风，
报改顶尾穿搭，
向上社交了李洪璋，
这个灰灰男，
拿下了革命胜利，
大结果，
可惜最后还是被短泽了，
只能说，
天资是一个很残忍的东西，
然后我以为，
同时日子人，
他会报效，
结果,
我完全听不懂，
我就得让他解释，
然后你知道幽默的天敌，
就是解释，
然后,
对，就是我要先从，
就是他每一个词我都听不懂，
就是袁世凯和李洪璋，
然后,
然后中间的所有词，
我都听不懂，
每次都感觉自己是古代人，
对于张平来说，
他听在的是，
袁世凯，
李洪璋，
东西,
是，跟他们同代人，
知道的词是一样的，
就俩人名，
OK,
我现在讲很多词，
我也听不懂，
然后,
昨天我跟朋友机会，
他们说什么，
大结果，
还有大苹果，
然后我当然，
我以为我听错了，
但是大苹果，
是那个，
语系里边的，
有一种类型吧，
一种,
办理的类型，
这是大苹果，
为什么会有这样的一句话，
就是因为整个互联网，
现在都充斥了，
各种各样的新的定义嘛，
那不同类型的博主，
就会创作出自己，
垂类,
或者说自己，
赛道里的专属定义，
专属词汇，
像,
情感博主，
它就会有各种，
比如说，
灰灰难，
就是灰产难，
向上社交，
就是你要认识大佬，
反正,
那我就会发现说，
这种互联网的这个氛围，
就导致，
其实不光是情感博主了，
就任何，
你只要是个博主，
你用你的垂类，
你都会，
给自己的这个社群，
创作出一些，
高度概括的，
魔症的定义，
来让这个，
你们社群里的人，
只有你们能，
听懂你们在说什么，
比如说，
心理博主，
它就会说，
教你怎么建定NPD，
PTSD,
ADHD,
回避型，
就有时候，
我都会觉得，
怎么这么多英文字儿啊，
比如说，
在里边，
混进去一些别的，
缩写你也不一定，
反映的过来，
比如说TOM，
汤姆的，
就是,
你根本，
跟我们造势什么啊，
你都会认为说，
应该是个很高级的，
新的心理学词汇吧，
其实不是，
对，你就反映不过来啊，
而且我也会想，
你说心理学，
它不是要求，
不许给没有成为，
医患关系的人，
下定义和判断吗，
但是心理学博主，
就是在每天教我们，
怎么把生活玩成浪人沙，
今天晚上，
查验一个NPD，
然后这个人，
是我查出来的，
回避型医恋，
所以他不对，
就感觉，
大家都充斥了，
各种各样的定义，
就是定义过剩了，
然后情感博主，
就是定义过剩重灾区，
你谈一段正常的恋爱，
可以被拆解为，
短泽和长泽，
你可以理解为，
短泽就是没有走到结婚，
长泽就是走到结婚了，
然后和别人谈恋爱，
那不叫谈恋爱，
持有,
那假如恋爱关系里，
两个人没有天天，
高消费，没有游玩，
只是在家做做饭，
打打游戏，
你就叫做低成本持有了，
我说挖了个琴娘嘞，
我说一个人的价值，
已经被谅化，
成了完全的价值定位，
然后从这些定义里，
我一方面是觉得，
魔症了，
真的世界魔症了，
一方面也觉得，
就是好像我们，
所有人都在被深深的误会，
没有别的东西了，
确实,
我还以为长泽，
就是两个人，
过一辈子呢，
还在这儿血呢，
这儿,
还装瓶一边听，
一边在那边拿着那个，
嗯,
像我的那种笔记本，
和签笔在那边写，
对,
这真的词汇太多了，
而且最近还有一个说法嘛，
就是说，
我们也已经进入了，
采访过剩，
或者意义过剩，
或者经济过剩的时代，
我但是，
看到这儿来说，
我说,
我们连对，
这个定义过剩时代的，
定义也过剩了，
就怎么有这么多的词，
去描述这个时代现象，
其实他其实就想说一件事，
嗯，尤其是那种采访，
相关的中文博客，
大家很多人就说，
听得越来越累了，
每个故事都会，
体验出一个观点，
每一个痛苦，
都要升华成一种，
成长的一个落点，
包括每个人物采访，
最后都得抽卡他嘛，
还有那个，
一个照片，
下面叠好几行的，
金句切片，
然后最近就有一个博主，
叫黑皂崔绝山，
他就在视频当中，
提到说，
我们到了采访过渡的时代，
采访变成了，
平安生产的那种工业，
比如说，
他就说，
每个人都有自己的节目，
每个人也都在，
成为别人的嘉宾，
就是我们现在的人生发法，
论太多了，
我觉得他提的这个洞察，
其实一下子，
接中了很多人的，
还是挺精确的，
摩扇人这个词的出现，
就是因为很长一段时间里面，
呃,
我们当时，
真的有一种意义匮法，
乃至意义饥荒吧，
所有人都，
很渴望被看见，
或者解释，
拆解,
命名。
呃,
当时,
2023年,
像标记录采访的时候，
他早就提出过，
这种感受，
他说,
年轻人特别喜欢，
问他,
焦虑怎么办呀，
内卷怎么办呀，
他自己出来，
就澄清说，
我不觉得，
自己是年轻人的人生倒实，
很多问题，
大家明知道没有答案，
只是需要找一个人一起解释，
然后包括，
有一些心理学博主，
也是这两年，
特别流行嘛，
呃,
很多人其实都会，
跟我聊这件事，
和社会博主，
变成那种老医生了，
天天在网上坐台，
问着,
很多人都想去，
找他们被分析嘛，
但其实，
你当然也能够，
理解这种渴求，
因为命名和分析，
他会给人一种，
解脱的力量，
只要有病就要，
你就觉得生活，
还是有结发的，
尤其是这三年，
比如说，
在公共事业当中，
我们去写一些，
媒体的长文章，
呃,
我们都会，
运营会分析哪些句子，
那会画线，
然后就会，
去加强，
大家要写这些句子，
然后很长一段时间，
其实大家画线的，
都是理论，
就像,
刚刚小学，
突然利用什么，
爆慢了，
流动了，
现在信息什么什么的，
一到这儿读着，
就开始画线了，
就是他们一定要take away，
一定要打包，
带走一点东西，
你讲了半天的故事，
他说,
那你到底要，
让我学点什么呢？
所以,
后来我们就，
为了让，
这种画线句子更多，
我就会在生产过程当中，
也会让作者，
不断地去加这种分析，
去提供认知，增量，
要对大家熟知的现象，
有新的命名，
新的理解，
这其实就是前几年的，
我们的传播密码，
但是解释过多，
生产过多的时候，
你肯定还是，
就走向了意义过深的，
这种疲惫感，
包括以前我们觉得，
一个人坦露自己，
其实特别珍贵，
但是现在，
人人都在坦露，
都在做自媒体，
坦露它其实也会变成了，
一种内容，
生产方式和风格了，
这种泛化的解释，
本质上它其实，
并不是严证，
而是概括和减化，
复杂的事实，
它就是把很多，
细节都省略了嘛，
其实每个人，
个体经验，
并不能真的套用在，
这些什么，
NPD解释框架当中，
它反而会，
遮蔽我们真实的感受，
让我们很多时候，
就得到一个名次之后，
就不再继续往下下了。
嗯，是的，
我以为我们新闻，
最主要的是，
提供信息增量，
但是现在，
大家要的，
都是认知增量。
是的,
就不止要信息。
嗯,
像我也会有一个感觉，
就是,
我们看那种，
四个小时的采访，
并不是为了，
理解嘉宾的，
而是为了，
从这里找到，
我们本来就认可的价值，
或者说，
就是我们看，
四个小时，
记住的东西，
是我们，
早就已经，
在心里有这个，
共识的，
只是来找回声，
而不是心知的。
就比如说，
我看那个，
鲁玉采访斗文涛，
三个小时，
我只记住了，
斗文涛小当，
遗产继承人，
想当富二代，
看那个王硕采访，
说自己一天，
呃,
刷十个小时短视频，
我就,
只传播这个，
一天刷十个小时短视频，
因为我也这么干，
所以,
我会觉得，
为啥,
金句广为流传，
一方面，
当然,
它是高度凝链的，
然后能够take away的，
第二方面，
就是,
其实是，
我们现在也只公明，
自己早就已经，
认可,
过无数次的那些金句，
就如果是这样，
确实,
好像也没必要，
有那么多的采访，
因为,
规定道理，
我是想，
要通过别人，
表达自己的声音，
但当然，
我也会觉得，
有些采访，
它也不是说，
所有采访，
就是都是过剩的，
就比如说，
我记得，
嗯,
过年的时候，
看到那个，
鲁玉采访贾玲，
我又觉得，
从那个采访里，
也有得到些什么，
比如说，
贾玲说要，
正视自己的采访，
我觉得，
这个就是一个，
心之,
我突然意识到，
怀才不欲不用等，
你可以直接自己欲自己，
我正视我自己，
嗯,
是的,
现在的，
确实不仅仅是，
采访过载意义，
过载进去过载，
我觉得我们也是，
解释过剩了，
就之前，
王老师他说了一句话，
他说现在人，
不仅要看访谈，
还要看对访谈的解析，
还要看对解析的评论，
就是现在，
大家要的，
就是那种认知成就，
我觉得很，
很震撼，
好像确实是这样，
我大概，
get到了,
就是以前老师说那种，
你光听讲的不够，
你得理解，
然后就好学生，
你学了这个东西，
你要学会，
融会，贯通，
所以大家，
其实在认知上，
也在证作好学生，
解释欲咎，
意思的地方，
就是我们现在，
甚至很难允许，
自己只拥有第一反应，
就是你不能说，
我讨厌某某某，
你最好能说，
是因为他触发了，
哪一种社会情绪，
你不能说，
这个电影让我哭了，
你最好知道，
他触碰的到底是，
哪一个待机创伤，
就是原本一件，
非常简单的事，
就被层层的包裹，
直到他最终，
拥有了一些，
阶级性别心理，
时代和主体性。
那这就导致了，
现在的一个现象，
就是我们，
公众发生之后，
一定要叠假，
这个叠假，
本来是，
只在游戏中，
叠假防御的装备，
但是我觉得，
现在这个，
公共发言语境里，
它指的就是，
我们每一个人，
在发言前，
要先进行，
无限的免责声明，
比如说，
我说这个，
只是根据我的个人经验，
我并不是说，
都是这样的，
不喜误喷，
以上,
仅代表个人，
观点,
无意冒犯任何群体，
我知道我这样说，
可能不全面，
我只是想分享我的感受，
就是,
我们一直在忙着解释，
忙着防御，
嗯,
这种过程中，
就会让，
真正的交流，
和碰撞消失。
对,
确实是，
我觉得这个层层叠假，
就实际上，
就是因为，
大家已经有点，
害怕在互联网上的，
发言了，
我发了，
一个几百次的话，
它可能，
会在几年内，
提起来，
某一个人，
很多年，
很多年前我提到过他，
但他最近他防了，
那我之前，
关于他的，
可能防他什么的，
也会被扒出来，
然后我也会被连坐，
就是我觉得，
大家现在层层叠假，
其实,
实际上，
为了避免，
这种互联网文化战争嘛，
就现在的，
社会模证化，
也不仅仅是，
我们社会，
它是一个全球化的现象，
我最近在看那个音剧，
大家应该也都在看吧，
就是Tipitle,。
嗯,
点起脚尖，
就是他完全呈现了，
这种文化战争，
是怎么一步一步发生的，
就包括现在，
我觉得也是，
就是当我们在互联网上，
是一种，
防御的姿态，
或者我们，
为什么要答那么那么多的字，
就是因为我们害怕一些，
他真的会发生，
一些实际的暴力，
就是这个Tipitle呢，
他,
他就是，
他呈现的，
就是这种，
不同阵营和意识形态的人，
对彼此的偏见，
是怎么一步一步，
作用到现实的，
他这个剧集里，
没有什么，
恶人或者反派，
他就是展现那个过程，
就是一个非常非常日常的，
就是一个人，
他不小心，
把他锁在门外了，
然后他把他的钥匙，
给了他的邻居，
就是一个，
特别特别简单的事，
但是这种，
私人的不愉快，
还有大家，
政治语言疊佳，
整个,
网络情绪，
就开始一步一步，
侵入这种现实生活，
你就会发现，
每一步都会武器化，
他们最后一集的那种，
大家在，
每一个人都在说话的，
我觉得，
真的不亚于一种，
战争场面，
一端暴力就发生了，
我有看那个，
主创采访，
这个编剧，
RTD,
他接受采访的时候，
他就说，
这样一部剧，
围绕着一件事展开，
就是,
除柜里的一个玻璃，
被放错了位置，
他没有被放在，
他应该放的地方，
这其实非常像，
我们现在生活的世界，
一条短信，
就可以毁掉你，
所有的事情，
都可能产生巨大的后果，
就是你可能，
六年前说的一句话，
他会一遍又一遍地回想，
不管你多么想让他，
停下来，
多么努力地，
想让他停下来，
他都不会停，
这个剧，
就是有这种，
非常小的事儿组成的，
就像我们的生活一样，
每一个念头都会被放大，
每一种偏见都会不断的，
从现实中，
找到新的佐证，
RTD他有一句话，
他就说，
It's a whiplash word,。
我知道 whiplash这个词，
就是从女团，
iSPA的那个 whiplash,。
这个词原意，
就是,
头颈,
突然,
前后甩动，
造成的那个伤害，
他就比喻剧烈的，
突然的反转，
这句话的语境里头，
就是,
他说的是一种，
互联网的现状，
就是说，
现在的，
不管是推，
还是假命的微博，
评论区，
短信,
群聊,
这种交流方式，
他都是非常短，
非常快的，
非常容易脱离，
完整语境的那个刺激，
比如一个截图，
你明明不是表达那个，
但被人截图之后，
他就,
不断地二创，
不断地隐身，
不断地被解释，
被研究，
你刚看到的，
一句冒犯你的话，
你就立刻愤怒了，
下一秒你又看见一件事，
然后一句话不断地，
截图,
转发,
重新解释，
之前的一句话，
重新出现，
我们现在，
所有的运营都告诉你，
就说,
你一定要对你写下的，
每一个字都非常慎重，
因为,
互联网不再有，
删除这个选项了，
就是,
不可能没有痕迹了，
所以所有的事情，
都非常短，
非常猛，
而且不给你消化时间，
人的情绪，
不是缓慢移动的，
而是在两个极端之间，
被反复抽甩的，
就是,
H.O. Whiplash World,。
这个世界，
不断地在，
猛拽我们的神经，
有的时候，
会觉得我们，
之所以不断地解释，
就是因为，
也有可能是，
我们害怕被攻击，
因为我们现在，
失去了那个，
容纳这种，
含混,
误解,
后悔,
和改变的，
这么一个环境。
我刚才听你说，
Whiplash,。
我觉得，
在中文语境里，
最好的翻译，
就是反转，
在场上，
看一个什么信息，
或者看一个新闻，
甚至是吃瓜，
就说,
呃，瓜反转了，
然后这个人，
本来以前，
大家认为是好人，
然后出现了一个什么事，
反转了，
他是个坏人，
就包括，
为什么，
我们一直在，
分析花哨二，
我们也是一直在反转，
就是一直是，
今天,
五分钟的切片，
证明了，
宁静是坏人，
第二天，
五分钟的切片，
证明了，
毛阿敏是坏人，
就我们会感觉，
社会已经被切换，
一个一个，
人的那个复杂性，
是没有了的，
就一个人，
你不能既支持A，
又理解B，
一个明星，
不能既有缺点，
又有魅力，
一个公路世界，
你也不能既合理，
又能值得反思，
所以一切都是，
非常简化的战队，
你是支持A还是B，
你要么是好人，
要么是坏人，
你要么是盟友，
要么是敌人，
所以就很多人，
选择退回到自己的生活里，
过日自己的小日子嘛，
就是现在，
我们这个过日子人的趋势，
呃,
那对于我们这期节目呢，
我们靠科罗斯过日子，
再次感谢，
科罗斯，
赞助本期节目，
开玩笑，
不好意思啊，
我们这种过日子人，
就是这么缠媚，
有空就缠媚一下金主，
好,
太日子了，
那我们就到下一个阶段，
就是,
也是现在流行趋势嘛，
当信息太多了之后，
我们就开始想当过日子人了，
我们就想往具体的，
我们的生活里退了，
第一个我觉得能够证明，
这个趋势的就是，
我们日子人开始反扑，
模证时刻了，
我们开始重塑那些，
网上的金句啊，
热词啊，
就比如说，
我们会重新用，
高度,
定义的词，
会去解释过去的一些东西，
然后让这些东西，
变得很搞笑，
我也给大家，
出了一个测试题，
让大家知道，
我们这个日子人，
是怎么，
重塑,
大结果，
这三个字的，
请做答，
我下面这句话，
是在形容，
国文学名著中的人物，
第一题，
人物,
男,
他通过向上社交，
跟过三位男嘉宾，
目前,
正在称，
第三位男嘉宾，
低骨期，
让他静身触碰，
是假保育吗？
错,
但是,
三国演艺中的，
女部,
三姓家奴，
第二题，
人物,
男,
他的资产A0，
在职业发展过程中，
领养了三个男球，
家里无助力，
本身是孤儿，
但是通过，
向上社交，
结实了大苹果，
曾经有，
顶级A10,
女大佬，
抛出橄榄汁，
希望,
这位人物男，
进入围城，
我从人物男后面，
就已经在听天书了，
什么男，
答案是，
昂苏,
三个男球，
领养三个男球，
到底是啥？
男孩,
就是男孩，
粉球,
他在这个，
西天取决过程中，
在职业发展过程中，
领养了三个男球，
家里为什么无助力呢？
因为,
将留二十孤儿，
向上社交，
为什么说他，
结交大苹果，
因为他是，
对外叫，
玉帝,
就是皇上的弟弟，
然后,
顶级A10,
女大佬，
就是女儿国国王，
那再说回我们，
主播各自的生活，
其实,
作为日子人，
我们自己也会有那种，
想要反扑，
扑魔政人的时刻。
对,
我觉得，
我当编辑的时候，
就最常说的一句话就是，
那有什么事吗？
就是问，
现在的同学们，
因为,
现在的作者都很，
都很小嘛，
就是,
可能刚刚毕业，
大家真的都非常爱说观点，
爱说判断，
也不仅仅是那种，
短视频，
或者是，
微博啊，
小红书啊，
这种社交平台发的，
就哪怕在长报道中，
我觉得，
大家也逐渐地魔政化，
就比如一个，
刚才方丹说的，
那些当你引用，
一个什么，
流动性耐性，
你只要出现，
暴漫的名字，
大家就会下滑线，
但实际上，
真正的，
深度报道，
或者是，
好的报道，
它,
会让你不提某一个人，
不用,
不用任何引号里面的东西，
它让一个，
只认字的人，
看完这一篇，
它也会觉得，
原来它在说的是这个，
而不是说什么，
官僚体系的庸种，
或者是什么，
现代性的反思，
就类似这种，
你不用这样子讲，
就是因为，
大家需要的是，
从故事中，
体会到，
你就是在讲这个，
你就是在讲现在的问题，
那个事情，
是更重要的，
就刚才，
张平说那个有事儿吗，
我现在，
我最近就有一个，
特别深刻的体验，
就最近有一个，
姐妹找我，
说是想让我，
帮他分析，
他现在这个亲密关系，
我说好，你说，
结果他在，
整个分析过程中，
我就一直在打断他，
为什么，
因为我听不懂，
他说到的，
全部关于他们俩的情感，
都是定义，
一个事儿都没有，
就是比如说，
我说怎么了，
他说，他呀，
最喜欢的，
就是用焦虑，
去回避问题，
我说，他怎么回复的，
给我圆画，
圆画,
你不然我怎么分析啊，
然后,
他就不给我说事儿，
嗯，我有时候，
会觉得，
我们的关系里，
是有一些，
犹疑和退确的，
有一些没有办法，
被确定和定义的东西，
我说到底是什么，
这东西是什么，
恨急,
大家现在用的，
都是那种，
就是你找豆包给你分析，
然后豆包分析出来的语言，
大家就用那个语言，
去解释自己的生活，
但实际上，
豆包也是先了解了一个事儿，
然后他才给你总结盖库，
然后才给你出金句，
才给你情感分析嘛，
但现在经常，
就是直接一个大的定义，
我说,
没有具体的事儿，
我真的不知道从何分析啊，
所以在，
我们这次交流过程中，
我就一直在崩溃，
我就,
你知道我说，
举例子，
给我例子，
对,
说到最后期，
就是张品的句话，
有事儿吗？
对,
就是跟我听那个，
什么向上社交，
在三个篮球节交，
回回来，
我都付出不出来，
其实,
你翻译出来，
它就是一件事儿嘛，
但我最近也发现，
就是你刚刚菲菲，
讲到那个情感咨询，
因为我之前，
很多朋友对我的社交期待，
也是,
类似承担一个，
心理分析师的作用，
比如说我最近也有一个女生朋友，
她是,
被男朋友，
提了分手，
然后那个男生就说了，
她诛咄诛咄的，
各种各样的问题，
觉得他们哪里不合适，
大家觉得非常的伤心，
她就给我，
非常严肃地约了一个，
一个小时的电话，
然后还排了好几次，
然后我们终于排上了，
她非常仔细讲，
她们吵架的全过程，
附上了聊天记录，
几十页，
然后一页一页地看，
然后我看完之后，
就非常，
狠狠地一顿给她分析，
说这男的，
可能家庭怎么样呀，
我了解她更多的信息，
她什么样的家庭，
那她可能是什么，
创伤投射到了你身上，
结果我发现，
现在这个东西，
她不work了，
就是我跟她聊完之后，
她还觉得，
好像还行吧，
但也就那样，
但第二天呢，
她跟我说，
她彻底好了，
我说怎么好的，
她说她约了一个，
泰罗牌资讯，
人家算出来说，
这男的，
她就是出轨了，
甚至这个泰罗，
是阳系的，
我们画出了，
出轨的那个女生的画像，
说对方是一个，
适合的人，
她穿什么颜色的衣服，
然后什么发型，
然后什么，
喜欢美黑这类的，
然后朋友听完之后，
分享给我，
说她如是重负，
然后我说，
就是,
我那个，
看了你五十多页的聊天记录，
然后,
狠狠一顿分析，
其实完全抵不上泰罗牌，
你早说嘛，
那我也能给你算，
确实,
我觉得也挺有道理的，
为啥你非得要去理解一切，
你要去，
理解人家什么家庭创伤，
可能导致她收出什么样的话，
有可能她就编的，
她就使出尾了，
不哀了，
没那么好解释的，
别分析了，
就是个渣男，
一下子，
原来是这样，
对对对，
是的,
我现在也是，
感觉我之前的这种路径依赖，
有点失效了，
这句话就很多证人，
你看,
我还在调理过程当中，
就是,
我之前很喜欢，
或者用这种抽象的，
盖过话的语言，
我觉得她可以让我表达，
或者我的信息传递变得很高效，
但是现在，
我一直习惯用这些方式，
去处理各种问题，
包括谈恋爱，
但是也失败了这么多次了，
现在已经到第十六位嘉宾了，
我也累了，
然后最近，
二十八年的老摩振仁，
也是开始调理了，
而且着有逞效吧，
这是怎么回事呢，
其实我也是被骗进去调理的，
就是我跟上一位嘉宾分手之后，
最近逮到了一位我的同行，
她就是把我骗进去调理了，
因为她的学科背景是，
我学本科，
比较文学的硕士，
认识她之前，
我先认识的她的稿子，
和她的论文，
黑画不少，
看完之后，
我就觉得很欣慰，
我觉得我们肯定很聊得来，
就像羽毛球一样，
我一个主体性，
你一个存在主义，
就是有来有回的，
辩论的时候，
就是可以电光获实的，
很有激情，
结果她让我心动的，
第一个瞬间，
还是不说话的时候，
我家包的时候，
我让她给我煮包辛拉面，
结果她，
现场去买了两番茄，
炒出沙了之后，
再加汤底，
然后打了两盘新蛋，
撒上葱花和香菜，
当时我看到这碗面的时候，
我就觉得，
这肯定不是，
只加汤底这么简单，
我就问她加了一些赏，
然后知道她做了非常多的工作，
但我最开始，
只是想要一个素食的，
快捷的食物而已，
然后当时，
周五凌晨一点钟，
我写到这儿，
我说我好饿，
然后她就立马又给我，
下了一碗面，
是远味的金拉面泡面，
但是她加了芝士条，
小裙带菜，
还有几滴香油，
和蟹肉棒等等，
一些海鲜，
嗯,
就会,
出现很浓郁的奶香，
因为那个芝士煮熔了之后，
它可以和那个金拉面的味道混合在一起，
强烈建议大家试一下这个配方，
总之,
我就是被她移了一个菜，
所打断，
我当时就跟她说，
没想到你做饭和蟹膏，
羊中有追求，
嗯,
然后我当时就一边夸她，
一边写这个波克稿，
然后一边筷子，
就是飞速的在那个泡面，
你捞的就只剩渣了，
我还在捞，
她就说，
把你这筷子换成奖，
能把奥德修斯送回家，
给你这筷子放海里，
能把菩萨头捞起来，
这嘴特别碎，
啤里巴拉，
说一大堆，
其实就是毫无意义的一些话，
但是我觉得特别逗，
就是我跟这个日子人，
过日子之后，
我才发现，
其实我没有那么喜欢抽象到，
那些议题的讨论，
或者我不是只喜欢这些东西，
只是我这些身边，
根本没有出现过这样子的日子人。
如果是真的情感博主，
听完铃猫这么分析一通，
会评价铃猫，
是被低成本持有了。
就一碗泡面，持有。
太好笑了。
我觉得，
我是一直都比较爱干净的那种人，
但是确实是，
清洁对我来说是一种解压，
而不是压力，
我就特别喜欢，
画一个下午，
就听着播客，
或者音乐，
把家里一点，
一点收拾干净的感觉，
就当时我看那个，
电影世界的主人的时候，
他不是有，
主角和朋友们一起清扫吗？
我就觉得特别准，
就是清洁是，
重建秩序感的一个方式，
看完电影之后，
我就有找那个导演的采访，
记者就问说，
为什么，
女性共同体，
定期作券活动，
电影里，
其实并没有用说明性的方式，
但是,
日常的描写出来，
他说,
你希望，
性暴力，
受害者，
自助小组，
以怎么样的方式，
把电影，
导演去把活动，
选定了清扫，
他就说，
因为那些，
并非在自愿情况下，
失去对自己人，
说和身体控制力的人，
在恢复这种，
控制感的过程中，
清扫,
或者洗碗，
据说,
可以帮助他们，
重新找回控制，
整理某些东西的感觉，
我想让人们，
去那些，
失去生活力气，
人们居住的房子，
也就是，
所谓的垃圾屋，
让他们把空间，
重新整理得很干净，
所以,
回到,
并不是撤退，
有的时候，
真的是重新建立，
对生活的控制感，
当时看，
这个世界的主人的时候，
我就一直，
在哭,
就是他们，
在整理东西的那个时候，
就是他可能，
并不是一个，
很常见的哭点，
但是我就，
一直在哭，
然后我后面看，
我完全理解这种，
就是,
当你的生活，
发生过巨大的，
冲击或者变动，
你在,
重新恢复，
这种,
控制感的过程中，
他清扫，
他就是，
一种,
非常重要的，
东西的感觉，
你其实，
在清扫的那种，
过程本身，
你就只有你和你自己，
你清扫的，
可能也是，
脑袋里面的一些，
坏念头，
或者是一些，
情绪上面的，
坏情绪，
我自己一直，
会觉得家务，
并不是一个天然，
应该被消遍的，
劳动类别，
尤其是，
那种,
维持自身孕短，
那种劳动，
我总觉得，
冰箱里面有食物，
有一个，
你自己舒服的，
东西在哪儿，
你都知道了，
舒适的家，
感觉到有一个，
微妙的区别，
就是,
张平享受的是，
他在状态好的时候，
主动去整理，
那种秩序感，
而不是，
每天都要，
天呐,
家里这么乱，
我得赶紧收拾，
那种被迫感，
所以我，
我会想，
可能他希望，
就是,
能够在想整理的时候，
去整理，
就是他说的，
控制感嘛，
而不是，
就已经乱到，
没有办法了，
然后,
不得不去，
做家务的时候，
而且之外，
我还很喜欢做饭，
就是,
你做饭的时候，
经常会有一种，
很平和的感觉，
就是为了说，
做饭的时候是完全，
不听播客，
也不听音乐的，
就只是做饭，
做本身那个饭，
就是,
你会觉得，
你身上留过，
很多人的痕迹，
也会觉得那个，
是一个充满爱的过程，
就比如，
当时我在上学的时候，
我的室友教我用，
香菇,
他就说，
用香菇，
你要用卖当劳的那个纸袋装，
他会保存的更久，
就不要用那个塑料袋，
或者不要，
就放在他那个包装盒里头，
然后香菇蒂呢，
一般大家做饭的时候，
不都会丢掉吗？
但实际上，
你把它香菇蒂洗洗，
你切成那个小丁，
就是刚开始下锅的时候，
你用那个小火慢煎，
它香气会特别浓郁，
然后我也非常喜欢炒菜的时候，
弄一个香叶，
就是你点燃香叶，
然后你再把它放进锅里，
再炒,
之后那个火合叶的香气，
就会被锁进油里，
这是跟另外一个朋友学的，
然后每年他家，
他都会给我一大包香叶，
那个香叶就是他奶奶家，
香叶树上的那个叶子，
当然最多的还是我妈教我的，
就是我现在又会做馒头，
又会做面条，
这也都是我这两年学会的，
我妈当时叫我做馒头的时候，
我就特别紧张，
就是当时发酵的时候，
我就一直在那儿盯着，
一直在那儿盯着，
我说能不能上锅，
能不能上锅，
我一直在问，
然后我妈就告诉我说，
稍等等，
它会长大的，
然后我就一直在看那个，
馒头和馒头之间的距离，
他就说，
你等,
你等差不多原来是。
十指的两个指节，
然后最后缩短到一个指节，
他就会可以了，
然后我们，
当时把那个馒头拿起来的时候，
它就变得特别特别轻，
就是一个面团，
本来你揉好它是很沉的嘛，
但它变得很轻，
我们两个就在厨房里头尖叫，
就特别快乐，
就觉得哦，
原来轻营是这种感觉，
就那个馒头特别像一朵云，
就实际上我们也是用食物。
来盲定时间的嘛，
就像夏天的时候，
你就吃水煮菜，
吃素瓜豆，
吃虾,
然后加上一点酱汁，
但是等到了秋天的时候，
就该吃那个豆米火锅了，
就该吃一些热腾腾的菜了，
吃南瓜了，
你就觉得哦，
秋天这个时候该来了。
食物里那些流动的情感，
这种传递，
然后还有这种治愈感，
我都很享受，
我也很喜欢摸香菇背面的那个褶皱，
但确实就是，
比如说厨房粘在地上的油汙，
食物垃圾桶周边的消毒啊，
就是这些清洁上的细节，
如果能也能被接收走，
那真的做饭，
就是完全只剩下，
最最喜欢的那些瞬间了。
我觉得刚刚听张评讲，
这一段我不知道听中，
大家有没有一样感受，
就是特别有画面感，
特别沉浸，
尤其像那个馒头间的距离，
从十指的两指节，
速量到一个指节，
我正在看自己的手，
然后想象它那个馒头变宣的过程，
这个桥也是最近更别的那种，
人才学到的嘛，
描述词汇的各种语言。
嗯，但其实，
在做饭的这些美好的时刻，
背后还是有很多，
反中的具体的家务劳动，
你还是要去承担，
比如说，
如果你厨房的那个垃圾桶，
它有很多的油，
从桶里露出来，
让你要去处理，
其实这些都是很繁琐的事情。
嗯，我也想分享一下，
我的过日子的时刻，
对于过日子的人，
我不知道是只有我这样，
还是别人也这样，
我常常词不答应，
就是,
我觉得在，
以前我还没有学会磨症的那些时刻的时候，
我经常没有办法，
能够准确的说出我心里想说的东西，
所以我在那些时候，
慢慢的就选择了用手工去代替，
就我表达不出来，
我想说的那一刻的情感，
我就用手工代替了。
嗯，比如说2017年，
我姐的第一个孩子出生了，
我特别特别爱她，
我就发现我对她表达爱的方式，
就是我每次遇见她，
我就想，
给她做手工，
摆弄她，
就比如说那时候在，
以前在北京的时候，
基本上就是，
一两个月见她一次嘛，
那每次带她出去玩的时候，
我就会问，
你想要什么样的发型，
我就在家里开始给她梳头发，
编头发，
后面她就长高了一点嘛，
然后我姐，
送了我一台缝刃机，
我想感受她大概的那个胸围，
是什么样，
问问她的体重和身高，
然后我就会在网上开始，
选漂亮的布，
给她做衣服，
然后剩下的料子，
就做一个发圈，
想能够搭配她的，
整个身高，
然后后面在，
我姐分享的她日常里，
看到她穿我那些，
做的衣服我都特别，
哎，又是词不答应，
我无法说出来那个感受，
然后包括我在职场上，
生活上遇见一些朋友，
我其实，
会希望我们能有一些，
属于我们的独一无二的东西，
就以前小时候会搞那种，
什么有情手链，
或者有情戒指，
那我,
可能年纪已经很大了，
我没有办法再说这种话了，
所以我就开始，
做手工送给他们，
比如说五年前，
我是迷上低焦，
我就根据每个人的喜好，
开始制作一些，
低焦的纪念品，
我就记得当时，
是张平他家里有一缸，
养了很久的金鱼，
然后我在网上，
找了做金鱼的小模具，
还有那种，
鱼缸的小模具，
买了流沙油，
就可以做一个，
鱼在水里，
油的一个挂架，
然后最近一年呢，
我就,
特别信策策，
里边会有，
提升磁场的好物，
各种水晶，
各种材质，
我穿这些的时候，
我都会想象要怎么搭配，
就是他对应了一个，
什么样的心情，
更重要的是，
其实很多，
情感,
我没有办法准确表达，
比如说，
像思念，
感谢,
牵挂,
我就是用，
手工去实现的，
所以现在，
对我来说，
手工就是我的，
缠休时刻，
我梳理自己，
情绪的时刻，
而且在这种，
家务型机器人，
进入生活之前，
有几次，
我就,
光做,
手工的准备工作了，
结果准备工作，
就是收拾屋子，
就先累个半死，
因为你还没开始缠休呢，
你就得，
脱地,
吸毛,
擦桌子，
尤其是，
做那种，
低焦,
捏捏累的，
那环境不能凑合着，
就是你毛不稀，
你真的会影响，
你做手工的治疗，
所以,
你想开始做手工，
想开始缠休，
咱们这种，
日子人想要纯享的时候，
也真的不是那么容易的事儿，
然后我以前是以为是我，
这个,
手工的内容原因，
才这么累，
直到我听完张平说，
我才意识到，
累不是我一个人的，
听友们肯定也会有同感，
我就想到一个说法，
就是说，
过日子，
其实就是用，
家务对抗，
伤增的过程，
就我们老说，
家务家务，
好像家务是一个火，
但其实，
你只要是日子人，
你就知道，
这个家务，
就是无数个，
非常细脆的火对待一起，
而且,
永远都没有纸巾的，
你要收拾起来，
都很累的。
是的,
而且我们说，
家务不仅仅是，
清扫地面，
因为我们也是，
居家办公比较多嘛，
然后电脑办公，
看书比较多，
还是需要爱护眼睛的，
其实也很需要那种，
统统的自然光，
像我们休息一会儿，
跳往远方啊，
看远处啊，
那窗户肯定得是，
刚刚静静的吧，
不然阳光透起来，
都是雾蒙蒙的，
但是等我们，
先擦窗户，
搬凳子，
架梯子，
探出去搬个身子，
然后手臂够到极限，
整个人非常悬工，
每次擦玻璃的过程也是，
非常恐怖，
而且擦完手型都是汗，
就一个过日子，
真的给人扯出，
不少家务活。
每一个场景，
都有不同的空间，
环境和任务要求，
想到这些，
就会很想大汗，
我说有没有人，
能来救救我，
说好的科技改变生活呢，
我需要科技产品，
现在就，
进入我的生活。
这就是，
我们本期，
节目赞助商科博斯，
一直想强调的，
一种品牌主张吗？
日常生活当中，
其实很多时候，
我们想去创造，
或者想去过日子，
但是还是有很多，
所需的事情，
会给我们增加这种，
压力。
世界上不可能，
真的难事，
就直接消失掉，
但是可能有些，
我们不想做的，
却不得不做的，
所是,
我们是有办法，
去让它，
不再消耗，
自己的精力，
和意志力。
就像我们刚才，
说到的，
擦窗户嘛，
像科博斯，
你把它往玻璃上一放，
它就能自己规划路径，
贴边清洁，
你就是干别的行了，
回来窗户就是透亮的，
而且,
它还能自己洗脉部，
你可说，
现在这科技发展，
太快了。
包括就是，
你们说的，
很疲惫的地面清洁，
他们最新的那种，
洗地机器人，
其实就不管是，
厨房已经干了的，
降料啊，
卫生间的头发塞，
或者地毯上的沉满，
一台机器，
就可以针对，
这种不同的屋次，
都会有不同的清洁方案，
可以自动去识别，
要用什么方案。
嗯,
就像你设置好，
定时之后，
它自己就知道，
什么时候该出来，
比如说，
你出门一趟，
开始选你会，
一回家，
你发现地面，
就已经干净了，
你甚至感受不到，
它曾经存在过，
就这种，
伤增的过程，
它给你抹除掉了。
啊,
这就是我们过日子人，
最想要的，
嗯,
无感不打扰，
但活儿呢，
你都得给我干了。
对,
所以说到这个细节，
现在也是在品类上面，
做了很多的衍生，
它的COS品类，
就不止，
刚刚说的这两个，
还要包括，
像割草机器人，
泳池机器人，
专门负责收纳的，
巴戒啊什么的，
甚至连情绪价值，
也想到了，
比如说，
它们有一个，
仿山经济小狗，
叫毛团，
就可以读懂你的情绪，
可能会歪头看着你，
你开心的时候，
它会摇尾巴，
所以COS,
现在就不是，
一个一个产品的在做，
它是在尝试，
搭建一个完整的体系，
从平面到立面，
或者从室内啊，
到室外，
从身体到情绪，
它都想，
替大家去照顾到，
其实我觉得，
它们这种，
进化本身，
还就是挺服，
和过日子人的理念的，
提到COS,
大家可能，
这些想到的，
都是它很专注，
扫地机器人这个领域，
这个领域，
它们也做了二十多年了，
但现在，
它们就开始，
进化成，
想要,
所谓的全方位，
照顾到你生活当中，
诸多困难处的，
对，而且可能，
这就是，
过日子人和魔政人，
对科技的不同想象了，
就是可能，
魔政人想象的科技，
AI能帮我写代码，
让我变得，
更自我实现，
但是日子人可能想要的科技，
就是,
给我真正地，
解决我生活的东西，
就你不用教我做事，
也不用给我分析我的精神，
你就把我现实中的，
脏活累活干了，
省下的时间呢，
我就可以去发呆，
听歌,
或者是，
什么都不做，
那像现在，
提到家务，
第一反应就是，
交给柯沃斯，
柯沃斯就是，
让我的生活，
变成了黄箔，
那首歌里，
八十平米的小窝，
还有一个，
哈拉波，
哈拉波就是柯沃斯，
然后,
他把窗户擦干净之后，
我就可以看，
伟烂的天空，
因为黄箔唱那个，
每次都是用青岛话唱的，
就是,
看伟烂的天空，
嘿,
然后就开始，
哈拉波，
但我们现在要，
讨论过日子嘛，
我们其实也要想，
过日子真的是一种，
自由,
还是只是，
因为我们累的，
没力气，关心别的，
就是,
我们也，
确实不能说，
鼓励大家，
每个人都说，
过日子人，
我们每个人，
只要过好自己的，
小生活就行了，
因为这实际上，
也是放弃了，
行动和改变的可能性嘛，
就是,
毕竟我们在，
生活在一个社会中，
在一种公共性和个人之间，
嗯,
寻找一种平衡，
包括我们三个人，
都是媒体出身，
你在关注一个议题的时候，
你最多关注的，
还是它的公共性，
就是我肯定，
所有的东西，
也并不是说我个人的，
而是我，
还是希望有行动，
和改变的可能的，
对于我这个过日子人来说，
我其实是个逆潮流的，
就,
开始慢慢意识到，
那些模认时刻，
其实也是很重要的，
因为我，
这几年也开始，
想要去发生嘛，
但我就会发现，
现在的发生环境，
跟过去的发生环境，
是完全不一样的，
因为我们现在，
集体就撤退了，
回到我们自己的小空间了，
那公共空间，
就探索了，
没有人了，
嗯,
就是如果我们，
现在把过日子，
只简单地理解为，
每个人都只过好，
自己的生活，
完全不管其他人，
只成为一个，
只要在小圈子里，
有舒适的生活，
就不用去，
在一大环境的变化的人，
那,
其实你就放弃了，
行动,
和改变的可能性，
放弃了公共的生活，
你就是，
只退回到你自己的小圈子嘛，
但是当然，
另一方面，
我也能够理解，
就是我们现在这种退，
它可能，
并不是一个主动选择，
而是为了，
撑住,
的一个暂时的选择，
那,
毕竟现在的公共空间里，
到处都是，
在找敌军，
找友军的人，
那,
如果你每一次发言，
都需要逐字逐句的，
去分析它的安全性，
你每一句话都要叠加，
你肯定很累，
所以想退一退，
想休息一下，
这样长的，
对于这些事，
可以兵法一下，
就是,
撤退,
是策略性的，
它不是永久的，
就,
敌皮我进，
敌进我退，
敌退我打，
当外部的噪声太大，
定义太多，
解释太密，
我们就可以暂时，
退到具体的生活里，
那,
这个就是，
为了保存你的能量，
恢复感知力，
重新建立自己，
对真实的判断力嘛，
那,
有了这个，
我们就有了，
重新进入，
公共生活的力气，
嗯,
是的,
其实说白了，
我们也不是想说，
哪种生活方式是正确的，
就不应该抹症啊，
或者说，
哦,
应该怎么怎么样，
而是,
嗯,
你还是，
可能回到自己的感受，
作为标准，
你感觉到自己，
被,
这些舆论的声音，
所困扰影响，
你觉得非常的反噪，
你想要安静一点，
那你就去，
享受生活你，
可能,
感觉到自己又有，
恢复力气了，
想要去关心公共的时候，
又去回到公共当中，
因为这种讨论，
其实最容易划向，
刚刚前面说的那种，
二元对立的方向嘛，
嗯,
比如说，
我们,
说了这么多过渡产师，
和分析的批判，
那很容易就，
也会划向一个方向，
就是学习，
没有用了，
想那么多干什么，
这些人文设科的理论，
都别提了，
好好过日子就行，
那就又变成那种，
很古早的，
反制的观点了，
但真正的问题可能是，
嗯,
到底怎么样才能，
不让理论，
去代替生活，
而是帮助我们，
去理解生活，
这种解释，
嗯,
是不是变成了，
一种唯一的答案，
在遮蔽我们的经验，
我当时也有，
问GBT这个问题嘛，
到底什么叫做，
过渡产师呢，
这渡在哪儿，
他就回答说，
当一个概念，
帮助我们，
打开经验的时候，
它是工具，
但当他，
帮我们，
关闭经验，
他就变成了，
过渡产师，
我觉得其实，
说的还挺对的，
就是,
嗯,
产师应该让世界，
变得更加复杂，
而不是更加简单，
就是你回到，
这种,
或者梦中，
固定的产师，
你就远离了，
复杂的流动的生活，
但我们批判，
这种魔阵，
绝对不是，
反对人文教育，
而是说，
可能真正的人文教育，
它应该是让我们，
越来越，
面对复杂，
理解人性当中的，
灰度,
包括,
让我们知道，
世界的无限，
而非是有限，
让我们知道，
很多概念，
和理论，
都有边界，
有局限性，
我给一个人，
做了50道题，
我一年之后，
还是发现，
他有一个，
人性的真相，
我们可能会知道，
人的处境，
的确会受到，
结构的影响，
但你也会知道，
一个人，
也永远，
他不只是，
结构的产物，
知道身份很重要，
但是一个具体的人，
他没法被，
一心脸顺序，
男性,
女性,
中年,
这些标签所概括，
就是,
更多的是，
让我们看见，
世界上那些，
甚为被命名的，
曖昧的偶然的，
无法被，
归类的瞬间，
他其实，
不会让我们，
去减化生活，
加谨慎的，
去使用概念，
和下注判断，
以及刚刚，
张平还说的一个点，
就是行动，
和改变的可能性，
其实他，
可能也是在，
日子当中发生的，
我一直对一组，
概念印象很深刻，
就是以下的柏林，
提出的，
两种自由，
消极自由，
和积极自由，
这是比较适合，
这个选题，
所以就是想到了，
这段,
马上要重复，
就先进去，
我听到过日子，
说法的时候，
我第一个想到的，
其实就是，
这是不是一种，
免于被干涉的自由，
是我可以不去，
做什么自由，
但是,
我其实还是在想，
下一步嘛，
就是,
积极自由，
应该是next level,。
这是我到底，
想要做什么，
我真正能够，
去决定，
自己怎么生活，
成为怎样的人，
而不是我，
免于去过，
什么样的生活，
就是你回到生活，
日子当中去，
我拒绝，
一切的产事，
和更好的生活的定义，
但是,
你有可能，
只是一种，
被动的，
毁避,
就是我每天，
想聊选题了，
这就是累了，
你可能，
会在这种情况下，
好好吃饭，
要睡觉，
但你可能，
仍然没有力气，
真正选择自己，
想要的生活，
但更重要的，
下一步可能，
是我今天，
到底想干什么，
我有时间，
和经历，
和能力，
去决定，
我怎么去分配，
我的注意力，
是关心你，
是流,
还是看孙宇辰，
还是直接退网，
去买菜，
做一下馒头，
山西面面，
我到底能够，
主宰自己的生活，
因为它还是有一个，
前提,
就是你还是需要，
真的有，
经历,
时间空间，
去做出，
今天要干什么的决定，
就像,
菲菲前面说的，
你如果，
今天想做手工，
但是你，
又不是真的，
直接就能开始做，
你还得花一个半小时，
先脱地，
把口毛吸了，
把桌子拆了，
啊,
绝命读师的，
这工作坊，
都打造好了，
你猜,
能开始干，
但这个时候，
你其实已经，
心力,
已经耗劫，
它还是会有，
这种隐蔽的敌人嘛，
它不是，
一定是很大的事情，
但是就，
可能也是，
这段生活当中，
一些,
你不得不去，
做得很琐碎，
但是又，
很消耗，
你占据，
你经历的，
小的事情，
所以,
机器自由和，
消极自由之间，
它可能，
还隔着一些，
很具体的小事儿，
不能光是说，
我们,
有这种，
免于被干涉的自由，
还得尝试，
把这些，
不得不做，
给抹除掉，
去让自己有余力，
所以我现在理解的，
过日子，
它其实更像是，
把，力气花在，
我想要去花的地方，
那那些，
我不想要，
我也觉得，
真的不值得我，
花时间尽力，
但又不得不做的事儿，
那,
交给这个扫地，
机器人，
擦装机器人，
让他们把，
这些所说的事儿，
都干掉，
对我们这些，
不想当超级人类，
只想好好过日子的，
普通人来说，
这可能，
我最期待的科技，
就是每次，
到我们讨论，
回到个体，
还是,
公共的这个问题，
就是我就会，
总会想到那个，
丽景老师之前，
说了一段话，
他就说，
过去十几年里，
回到个体，
本来是一种，
非常重要的解放，
因为他意味着，
我们不再是，
某个宏大目标的工具，
不必为了，
国家,
历史,
阶级,
家庭,
或者性别角色，
去牺牲自己，
个体的经验，
记忆,
身体身份，
抗,
但是问题是，
当所有注意力，
都持续向内，
个体实际上，
也越来越难，
走向外部，
我们开始非常，
擅长,
辨认自己的身份，
编辑,
创伤和利益，
却并不一定，
擅长,
建立那个，
共同的生活，
我们常说的，
身份政治，
和个体经验，
他就是给我们，
提供了最初的，
复权,
他实际上，
让过去，
被忽略的人，
终于可以说，
这是我的经验，
你不能替我定义，
而不是我们，
之间的共同点，
比如,
我是女性，
你是男性，
我们属于这个群体，
你属于那个群体，
我和你的创伤，
是不同的，
我的位置，
和你的位置，
是不同的，
我们的利益，
也是不同的，
那最后，
我们,
会越来越容易，
回答我是谁，
我和你哪儿，
不一样，
却越来越，
难回答另外一个问题，
就是,
我们面对的，
共同的事情，
是什么，
这也是今天，
我们公共空间，
一个非常，
从阵营之间的分裂，
甚至在同一个阵营内部，
也会因为身份，
经验,
立场的纯度，
而不断的细分，
那这期播客，
我们也不是说，
要在魔阵人，
和日子人之间，
二选一，
我们当然，
可以拒绝，
每天都承担整个世界，
也可以拒绝，
不要把自己，
活成一个，
永远需要分析，
和收集的项目，
但是,
当那个注意力，
重新收回到生活，
和自己，
身上之后，
我们也要学习，
怎么样从自己的生活里面，
出去走向别人，
走向,
走出去的这个动作，
可能不是为了，
再次找到一个，
宏大的，
共同体，
或者是一个主意，
把我们所有人，
都绑定起来，
绑定在一块，
统一在一块，
而是去分一些，
更加朴素的问题，
就是,
我们有哪些，
共同的困难，
哪些事情，
就,
不是靠我一个人，
做精神分析，
能解决好的，
就是,
我们可以一块，
怎么着改变一下，
我们,
共同生活的，
这个社会和生活，
那最后，
我们,
再次感谢，
科沃斯对本期节目的，
赞助支持，
科沃斯用不同形态的，
机器人，
适配不同的，
清洁需求，
把室内事外，
那些细碎，
重复又不得，
不做的家务事，
一件一件的，
接过来，
让我们，
有余力，
做个真正的，
过日子人，
如果你家里，
有科沃斯那款，
机器人，
是你在日常里，
离不开的，
过日子扎子，
也欢迎来，
评论区，
给我们分享，
想要了解更多，